i'm gonna do this as i would direct
anybody else i only have two directions
for you mr dave control
the first one what is dark souls
yeah that's a that's a that's a heavy
question
pain and happiness combined into one
dark souls
[Music]
is a lifestyle for me it's a little
something different you know it's
it's kind of my life it's my job it's
it's what i keep coming back to that
makes people happy i have fun with and
and it's just it's just a blast it's a
whole experience on its own the game
literally changed my life and that
sounds really dramatic and nerdy but it
actually changed my life which is really
scary considering i've barely played the
game i guess the first thing that comes
to mind is all the characters and the
bosses to me all of their designs are
like etched into my mind as like super
iconic it's everything like everything
about dark souls you can't think of one
thing in dark souls and that's the way
the game is designed the first thing i
think of when i think of dark souls is
the you are that screen
i think of
challenge a really good challenge just
because that word has become synonymous
with the game at this point and at the
time i thought
the game was famous and it was popular
because it was so ridiculously hard um
which once you start to play those games
you realize that's not actually the case
it was realizing that well also the game
is it's helping me the game does not
want to fly to you but at the same time
it wants you to win
it's a challenging game but fair in a
way that makes you come to accept it
first and then appreciate it afterwards
because you start to learn that the
frustration and pain is part of the
process of it it's almost like a
religious experience where like you're
totally engrossed what seems completely
impossible the first time around
gradually becomes more and more possible
it's so fun to look back into and see
the things that you got stuck at that
now you can do effortlessly
and i think there's something so
universal about that
my first memory of dark souls is the
bartholomew trailer which was the one of
the first trailers for dark souls and i
remember it because i remember watching
that trailer and thinking this looks
like my kind of game
[Music]
it's a game that was
seemingly made out of things people
usually call
bad ideas i remember complaining that
there was no waypoint and i was like
well how am i supposed to figure out
where i'm supposed to go what i'm
supposed to do the world kind of seemed
a little bit boring to me um because
it's just you running around in dirt and
everything's grimy looking i'd played
skyrim before dark souls so i was like
oh yeah a fantasy game that's you know
colorful and green and luscious then you
can put in dark souls and it's like
no
depression i'm not into medieval
not for me and i just
didn't go near it dark souls is an
acquired taste people would would
describe their experiences and you would
think this is a negative review so
selling that to people is not an easy
task and i failed repeatedly out so the
smarter thing for me to do was just to
buy the game repeatedly and give it to
people first time i played it was more
just a kind of i'll fine i'll give it a
go then
my first experience playing dark souls
um
was i think like a lot of people it was
being squashed immediately by the asylum
demon that like gave me a heart attack
at first i feel like i remember doing
the plunge you know that takes basically
half a tells away and still not being
able to do it like to be honest with you
there's a lot of butt in your face right
off the get-go it's kind of slow and it
pretty much just sits on you like that's
like one of the things that it does and
the entire time you kind of got to stay
on the booty to beat it so like that's
that's pretty much the whole process
it's looking at the bud sheets and
yeah the first time i saw a big chunk of
my health bar just vanished i was just
like
oh no
got up to
the cat redemon i got in the room and i
was dead within five seconds
and i thought
i'm never playing this [ __ ] game ever
again
fighting the capra demon on the train i
got so into it and i
very narrowly defeated him like with
like a slither of health left and i was
so excited that i kind of kicked out in
that excitement at the moment and like
struck the man that was sat opposite me
right in the shin but i didn't care
cause i've beaten kaepernick i have been
warned that this game was so difficult
that when i initially was given a lot of
freedom to move in the many branching
areas i actually went to the hardest
possible area like by far the hardest
one and when i saw the game was so
difficult i i genuinely thought okay
this is just the very hardcore
experience i was promised um but then
eventually it dawned on me that you
maybe are not meant to go here yet i
went into the catacombs very very early
i just needed to go in there it was
right by firelink and it was just
calling to me and i eventually got my
way to the tomb of the giants and
there's this yellow fog gate
and i couldn't go through it and i had
to go all the way back up
it took me so long but i'll never forget
it and i love that game for it that's
something that dark souls does really
well it lets your hopes
ebb and flow you're not being punished
needlessly you're actually
being taught how to play at any time i
was ready to give up uh luckily i didn't
and and typically it was worth the the
effort later i would say most action
games i feel so overpowered and the fact
that the things actually are as
dangerous as they look in dark souls
was a really cool feeling i actually
like that feeling of a sense of
helplessness in a way and challenge so
any like moment where like you say
you're getting back to the hub area
you're doing like a shortcut is suddenly
like it represents
a big
help
my favorite moment of the game it was
such a great moment it was when so when
you loop back to firelink shrine from
lower undead burke you find a ladder and
you're like well why why is this ladder
what's this for and then you kick the
ladder down and go down to see the
bonfire and then you realize
oh god it's the beginning of the area it
was just like it was like overwhelming
amount of like emotions of like wait
it's all connected i had this moment
where all of a sudden
especially because you can't warp in
dark souls at least you can't warp in
dark souls until way later in the game
so it made that linking
that much more amazing of a moment in
other games like those shortcuts don't
hit the same you realize that everything
has a purpose and a place and a pathway
it's all intertwined and designed in a
way that was kind of mind-blowing i love
that moment it's so good i
am very glad
favorite npc is
they're all miserable
um
it's got to be onion night you gotta
love
the thick fat rolling boy just this
really happy kind of go lucky guy in
this really
desolate and depressing
[Music]
world i'm not going to say solaire
because everybody says solaire it's got
to be soleil it's got to be solo
everyone loves solaire for some jolly
cooperation always no matter what always
go down those little stairs to go giving
him a little visit to stare at the sun
with him just have a nice old time he is
encouraging jolly cooperation
he's optimistic and it's such a
refreshing character to you know be in
this game if i didn't know better i
think you have feelings for me i'm gonna
have to give it to law trek because
every time you talk to him he's like uh
yeah help me help me get out of this
prison cell and uh
i'll make it worth your while
and you're like okay
patches who was expecting that answer
nobody i like the fact that he tries to
[ __ ] with you all the time it's
hilarious it cracks me up he's such an
[ __ ] and it's amazing
and i'm so glad he's in every game
because he is the worst and best at the
same time i will never forget when he
pushed me off a ledge into darkness i'll
never forget it
this is what i do my friend
chester marvelous chester uh i firmly
believe that he slipped in through a
fissure he gets grabbed by the hand and
he's from yarn he's he's got the top hat
he's got a trick crossbow he's wearing
the hunter's set he talks like a
yharnamite i see the connection does it
really matter
[Laughter]
frampt because
nothing that looks like him should have
his voice nothing that looks like him
should legally be allowed to have flaps
coming out of his lips he shouldn't be
allowed to put you in his mouth
everything about him is disgusting and
wrong but also incredible and i love him
enough
i shall slumber
until i am awakened again
i love how dark souls bosses look like
they should just be able to step on you
but they don't the tourist demon ended
up
jumping off of
his arena and dying like instantly
[Music]
i didn't even find him
i think my favorite boss in dark souls
is actually
the bell gargoyles
it is the first time in that game where
you're presented with two bosses at the
same time
on a roof that has no fences my friend
as soon as people beat the gargoyle it
creates a feeling that you can
go on
to beat the rest of the game
yeah the sif battle is just incredible
you kind of have a slightly different
emotional experience with sif than with
any other boss it was kind of traumatic
that you had to
had to kill the puppers and it looks sad
when it looks at you and you're not
quite sure why because you haven't
experienced that story yet you find her
or him protected by what artoria's
shield realized oh you actually
saved that wolf in another timeline and
it remembers you from your smell this is
the first boss that starts to show the
pain of you having beat her down
ah it's too much
my favorite boss in dark souls is
probably artorias
being able to
see artorias was kind of like a big one
for me he was just amazing and stunning
and all of his glory i really like his
lore he's a literal legend and i'm
fighting a literal legend everyone loves
artorias and i'm not hating on him i
love him he's probably the best sword
boss in that game he's got to be
but manus with the eyes and the extra
long arm he's just such a beast
i couldn't believe what i've been seeing
what a presence and event that whole
entire fight is not only from a gameplay
standpoint but from a lore standpoint
the most hated boss in dark souls is is
obviously bed of chaos it's it's to me
it's just annoying i don't think it's
the worst i actually don't mind the idea
that they have this gimmick boss fight
with the witch of izalith it kind of
changes things up and to be honest my
first time playing the game i was kind
of like relieved just like oh thank god
don't put that in i get the idea i get
it
it's a gimmick fight it's cool there's
nothing wrong with that but i just don't
enjoy doing it bed of chaos is like i
hope you can jump in this game that
isn't very good at jumping otherwise you
ain't beating it and you're gonna be in
a hole
it just feels like luck half the time is
she gonna
sweep the floor and push you off
it's not it's not as bad as everybody
makes it out to be honestly it's their
their least well-designed boss it's not
even her i mean she's just a little
centipede thing
the player reaches sends fortress after
they have rung the two bells of
awakening
then you're told that you first have to
traverse this house of
hodders
[Music]
[Music]
it's just so weird and filled with traps
i think it's so fun everything about it
is just great and it's also like the
very final step you have to take before
reaching anor londo
anor londo all the way baby that's like
one of the iconic all-time moments in
gaming history i think it was quite an
experience just i think emotionally it
was a hit but also visually it was
amazing and orlando looks like a
beautiful
uh spanish cathedral while it's still
new the aesthetic of it as a whole and
all the architecture and how like
glorious it looked was great
then you hit ornstein and smoke
you enter the room you hear the music
you see five seconds of these two dudes
introducing themselves and that's all
you need to know
as soon as that cursing drops on scene
just
dashes at you
ornstein like a rocket just comes
shooting in between pillars like a
dragon ball z character i was gaining
confidence then they threw this this
thing out of left field with two bosses
at one time and i did not expect that
there's two bosses
and they're functioning independently of
each other this was the true roadblock
of the game with ornstein and smo this
is the get good moments there's
literally a whole video documenting how
many times i said
during that fight
[Music]
no no
i definitely thought this is unfair the
first time i fought him you know like
the first time you
that you kill one of them and all it
does is make the other one more powerful
and refill all their health you're just
like
why are you doing this to me this is
this is
so stupid are you
ah
that's also like the most dark souls
thing ever it's just so good it's just
so good you make it past or you don't
and you never touch the game again
ornstein and smog is a boss that i hate
about as much as i love and i bet a lot
of other players say that too oh i hated
it i hated fighting ornstein's mom
they were so tough that is probably
especially my first playthrough probably
the boss i spent longest it's not too
long after that you've realized just
exactly how they're going to torture you
for the next hours for some people weeks
yeah i remember getting stuck in them
for a solid three and a half hours three
hours fighting them put your feet up
because you're gonna be here for at
least the next five hours when you
finally get to the moment where you beat
them that's when that cascading of
everything that you've been holding in
for so long just falls out in that one
moment and you just feel everything that
you've been holding inside of yourself i
actually felt like we'd accomplished
something everyone who's played dark
souls
will remember
probably the moment that they'd be
almost in a smell i did it on my first
try i'm not even trying to brag i'm not
even trying to brag hardest fight in the
game no i don't agree in the slightest
as you progress
as with all the souls games you discover
that not everything isn't what it seems
you discover the biggest betrayal of all
you meet gwynevere and you're like i
made it i am the prince i am the hero
turns out she's fake
[Music]
miyazaki almost will do this thing in
his games where like you'll unlock
something or find a secret world or like
get access to something in a way that
almost feels like a fake thing that you
read online somewhere after you beat the
four kings and dark souls if you have
not placed the lord vessel yet one of
the snakes instead of frampt it's koth
appears
and
that was totally a self-imposed like
desire to beat this boss earlier than
intended or expected we were both just
like
what just happened it's stuff that
doesn't seem like it would make sense
but then when it happens you're just
like ah those are those are the cool the
secret moments when you kind of get to
transition into new areas they're always
the best
ashleigh is another one it might be very
small but i don't know i just feel like
it feels like a hidden away little
secret you hit one illusionary wall and
then you go and you have to hit another
one it's almost like you put so many
barriers to hide this thing to make it
feel like this
super intense secret that like you
weren't supposed to have access to to
find this giant hollowed-out tree that
you go down and then you find this
nausica valley of the wind style trees
everywhere
music all of a sudden kicks in which is
nowhere else in the game for the most
part which just makes it that much more
awe inspiring just a really cool place
to experience and discover for the first
time it's insane and it's so cool
especially when the music kicks in it's
just like wow
it's it's amazing i love ash lake i will
stick the blight down people hate blight
down i think it's one of the coolest
bits of the game the first low point i
remember in dark souls is blighttown um
which is probably a lot of people's
first terrible place the light no no no
no no no no it is a
jenga block tower of the worst
imaginable stacked on top of each other
and at one point in the game your job is
basically to get from the top of it to
the bottom of it oh i'll tell you my
least favorite bit the bottom of um
blighttown if that's a separate area if
you can count that
you just said you like blighttown you're
standing up for the bottom of it i
really like swamp
levels it's almost like miyazaki's like
you can't go here like it's poisonous
like you can't go any further and
i would be like haha no
like i'm gonna go before that was the
depths because i'm pretty sure i got
cursed everyone talks about blighttown
as being like this
like the worst place in the game and
it's this horrible poison swamp and all
this kind of stuff but
even to get to blighttown you have to go
through the depths i was one of the
lucky people that once i went into the
depths which is the seaward level where
literally anything and everything will
kill you i got cursed which is a really
rough status effect in this game and
that might have been the only point
where i was like okay maybe maybe i'm
really doing something wrong i just hate
it i just hate it it's rubbish i mean
it's not rubbish but i hate it
in terms of looks i actually
love lost izalith
i i love the city under the ground
obviously the the the dinosaur butts or
whatever that is and the bed of chaos we
can throw that out it's just lava and
then ass
with feet everywhere that area was
probably the segment of the game that
felt the most
rushed development-wise they were rushed
it's okay we forgive them
you can't say that it's bad except for
except for the the lava is like it burns
your eyes out but maybe that was
intentional
honestly it's like any time you talk
about it you're like oh it's such an
amazing game every part of it is
incredible except light town and then
past blighttown there's a bit in the
lava that's just [ __ ] terrible and
then but overall it's a masterpiece
i played it online so
i did play the pvp but not willingly
it's pretty rude
when people can just invade you and i
hated every minute of it i did play a
lot of the pvp in dark souls
and i apologize because i was an [ __ ]
getting that adrenaline rush with
someone would invade your game was so
cool and i loved it the pvp was cool
like invading someone else's world and
being able to ruin their day those first
impressions made it so much worse i've
got 20 000 souls can you just
like
i've been an invader myself and in kind
of
um
wrecked noobs as they say i
was the awful person who did like a
really low soul level run and i was
invading like undead parish
[Music]
i was making my own fun in dark souls
pvp but it was mostly bullying but
that's dark souls
do i have a favorite piece of music for
dark souls i feel like this question is
targeted at me it's a pretty background
music that plays when you're at firelink
shrine
i don't know maybe just because i've
spent a lot of time there it just kind
of soothes my soul i don't love the fire
electronic music because it's just music
it's because it's an ambience it's a a
mood it's a
theme it's a narrative this is where i
feel good this is where i feel safe it's
my home
the one that jumps into my mind at first
is the initial song that plays when you
fight the asylum demon at the beginning
i'm currently in the
process of creating a mod called lobos
sfx where i replace every single piece
of audio in the game with my mouth
sounds
i bet a lot of the answers would be
gwen's theme it's probably gwyn's theme
100 gwen the gwynn music the gwyn theme
not just because i heard it
many many many times just affectionately
referred to as plin plin plon it would
be what the the plin plan plan i feel
it's pretty iconic at this point i still
go back and listen to that how's when
skin go
parium stabbin
miyazaki's really big on making these
really big orchestral
almost like operatic compositions but i
think that the gwen one's so powerful
because there's like nothing
that piano is basically how gwyn really
feels which is that he's almost
pathetic but
still putting up a fight but the real
gwyn inside of him is like this again
man like seriously actually managing to
fight him and get through that fight we
cried out this is for solaire
it was one of the most incredible
gaming moments i've ever experienced
first time playing
when i beat the ending and lit the fire
[Music]
this is it that's it
what happened
that can't be it can it i wanted more of
a cutscene that that's that's honestly
what i wanted i wanted it to be a little
bit grander it sounds so naive and
stupid now but i guess i was hoping for
finally getting some kind of a clear
explanation behind things
[Laughter]
i was so confused and i think that's
what compelled me to go look up lore
videos online from epic name bro uh he's
so good i loved it so i linked the fire
the first time that i played the game
and when i linked the fire
it clicked it's not really a oh that's
it it's more of a
oh
i remember on my facebook group
the people and it hated the ending they
were like this is doesn't make any sense
i don't understand it and that's
actually how i started my youtube videos
was four people
in that pvp group so
we have gwen and he's kind of the center
of everything but he's not the oldest i
was like recording my my forehead with
my macbook camera being like no wait let
me explain this to you guys like well
it's not you know it's not it's not it's
not a bad ending like i promise it's
actually really good it was a different
way of telling stories in games that i
hadn't seen before and i like that
because i like when video games
tell stories in a way that other mediums
can't tell stories you really have to
change your expectation
um in the industry we call it game
learning it's a tricky and intricate and
complicated story only i know the truth
about your fate
the narrative of dark souls
as concisely as possible
oh
no
oh
that's a good that's a good that's a
good question
all right i'm so sorry daniel for what
is about to happen
so
you
in the beginning there are dragons fire
came
the soul
people took the soul got power there was
the the dude with the the beard quinn
this old man looks like santa comes
along and goes oh [ __ ] that [ __ ] i i
want a piece of that and then he throws
lightning at them with a big old army
and they find this flame that is able to
create life and uh like kindle this
great big kingdom of anor londo that
everyone is very like yeah you did the
kingdom thing it's wonderful doing a
good job good good for you and thus the
age of dragons ends and the age of man
begins but eventually the fire started
fading and they're like i want to live i
want to have my kingdom but all things
must die
the witch of izalith was like hey i'm
gonna i don't need your flame i'm gonna
make
my own flame so she tried to make an
artificial one and i'm pretty sure she
made demons and come out of the ground
but over time that flame started to die
out and the light in the world was dying
out they had one final contingency plan
have an undead do it kill everybody else
and by the time dark souls
starts
you are a human afflicted by the curse
and the gods have tried to stop the
curse by basically locking away humans
affected by it and
you are taken to what is called the
asylum it's essentially a big uh undead
leper colony you're the chosen undead
because oscar chose you
oscar's really god essentially he's
jesus he then gets hit by boulder
and you're supposed to go
rekindle the flame or choose not to
rekindle the flame so you
you go to one place you're sent on the
next part of your quest which is to
commit mass murder
and
so you kill gwyn and you light the big
fire and that or you don't
your choice at worst you're gonna burn
yourself in a flame at best you're gonna
be bossing around 10 serpents
[Music]
that was not very concise but yeah wait
maybe here we go okay i got it even
conciser even conciser conciser uh
undead guy
kills
other
undead guy
and then it repeats
so the real story of dark souls is
you're just a little guy
and you go around killing bigger guys
until
you kill them all and then
you uh
you light yourself on fire
or not
and that's the story a lot of people get
out of the game i'll i can let me do it
faster faster faster faster faster
faster human beef jerky is angry at the
gods
that's how i once sold dark souls to a
girl on a first date my dear fair lady
she cried for me the legacy of dark
souls is quite an impactful one so this
is coming from an industry perspective
because i'm working in the industry now
it's changed a lot it started a new type
of game or a new genre which is kind of
rare it's almost like a shorthand and if
you say you know something is souls-like
people who play video games know exactly
what you mean it's kind of a meme in
itself that everyone was like comparing
you know whatever game was coming out to
dark souls oh this is you know the souls
dark souls of shooters or the dark souls
of racing games or the dark souls of
property management simulators or
whatever what's interesting is how many
games are described as being like this
feels like it was influenced by dark
souls and they're not rpgs they're not
third person combat games it's got to
the point where if a game is hard
inevitably there'll be someone that'll
be like oh it's like a
dark souls like my objective like from
the outside looking in opinion it's that
they're gonna be known for the rest of
time as oh those games are difficult
hopefully its legacy won't just be
difficulty but
a good challenge to overcome it did what
every other developer
and every other design team would tell
you you shouldn't do in a modern video
game to have a hit dark souls tells you
exactly what you need to know and then
pushes you to go explore and figure
stuff out yourself and i think
especially now
um
that's something that we kind of take
for granted that like
games used to be more obtuse
and dark souls you know because
especially in now we have ubisoft like
sorry ubisoft but you don't have to have
the ubisoft eui hud with like all the
tutorials and the markers and the you
know you don't have to have that and
it's such a immersive
style of um moving through a game that i
think it ended up bleeding over as a
habit i've been turning off hud features
ever since i got into dark souls things
like that it's more about just putting
you in this world and respecting the
player putting everything back into the
players hands
after
a decade or two of
here's what you do player a game that is
difficult or hard to get through doesn't
have to be punishing or cruel or
malicious you're gonna think challenge
you're gonna think all those other
things with dark souls but one of the
biggest things to come from dark souls
is their death mechanic when you die you
leave behind a cache of experience
points that you can get right back as if
you never died at all if you were able
to
make as much progress as you did the
first time you hit some sort of fail
state there's like an illusion of
difficulty so failure is
failure is actually contributing to your
success that mechanic has become modern
game design it's kind of responsible for
teaching people a whole other language
on how to play games um
and that's just like scraping the
surface it's one of the most influential
games of all time one of the best games
of all time i just think it maybe not
only leaves a mark in the gaming
industry i think it also leaves a mark
in people's lives i've got
tattoos of a bone wheel skeleton and
some onion bros head the elite knight
armor on my arm and it's one of the few
franchises that i love enough
to throw on my body i know a lot of
people play the souls games when they're
going through a tougher time and it
really does
help them get through what they're going
through that feeling of
overcoming obstacles
that feeling of challenge
when you're in a low place
can be really helpful emotionally it's
gotten me through a lot of tough
experiences in my life because you can
just hyper focus on this game and
overcoming it it's also just taught me
not to back down from those challenges
be okay with failure and continuing on
from failure and to persist
until
you succeed at what you're doing and i
think it's a really
beautiful rumination on not just game
design and the way we think about
stories but on how we approach life
because i feel like that is life we
don't necessarily get a rule book on how
to figure out life some people will say
they have one like some of the people
that you encounter within the dark souls
lore and they're trying to figure it out
but we ultimately don't know
and we're just trying your best through
failure and maybe one day getting that
big success makes us feel like it was
all worthwhile it's gonna kick your ass
it should but that's part of the
experience the feeling you get when you
overcome something that's taking you
hours or days
man you don't get that from any other
game there's nothing like the first
experience of playing the first dark
souls it's one of the games i wish i
could delete from my memory just so i
could play it again
so you'll only get one chance at it so
appreciate it
[Music]
you